[Music]
a student protest camp blocking a busy
barcelona street says much about the
deadlock at the heart of spanish
politics we are trying to make like
conscious and to the young people that
we are growing up in are in a system
that in so many years will just fail
this is a generation that doesn't
believe its future is served by the
political infighting that saw socialist
leader Pedro Sanchez failed to form a
governing coalition after elections in
April
now Sanchez is hoping his gamble on a
second election in seven months Spain's
fourth in four years will pay off
locating his final campaign rally in
Barcelona the Catalan capital is meant
to send a message that he is best placed
to solve Spain's most intractable
problem the drive for Catalan
independence this is the Catalonia we
stand for the Catalonia that wants to
live in peace and not confrontation that
wants democracy and not violence
solutions are not conflicts the problem
for Pedro Sanchez is that while the
Socialists are predicted to win they
will likely once again fall short of a
majority and forming a coalition maybe
even harder this time than it was back
in April he wants to show that he has a
support to kind of like do you think
you'll succeed he'll get the balls I
don't know if he'll get the solution the
violence in Barcelona last month that
followed the jailing of Catalan
separatist leaders reignited the
independence debate and drove Spanish
public opinion to the right the
far-right Vox party that promises to ban
separatism altogether could emerge as
Spain's largest party and the
once-mighty conservative People's Party
is also on the rise leaving the
Socialists struggling for suitable
partners one option sanchez hasn't ruled
out is a tie-up with catalonia's
separatist parties that what they want
most he cannot give
play with both sides playing with the
left side he eventually left parties but
in the end he always end up making they
always end up dialogue you making deals
yeah with the right parties so the
political deadlock could well continue
and in the struggle for an independent
Catalonia stalemate
Jonah hole al Jazeera Barcelona